at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode's brought to you by
peloton and I'd heard about peloton over
and over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin Rose I've known him
forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic I asked him as a dude
you look great what the hell have you
been up to because he's always doing a
weird diet or another but it only lasts
like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you know if we're worried
about fitting classes in your schedule
or making it to a studio with some type
of commute etc new classes are added
every day and this includes options led
by elite New York City instructors in
your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and his iron high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics
think that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n 1 peloton calm
and enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say met accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip in
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so there's $100 off is a very
legit hundred dollars off so if you want
to get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one peloton calm and
enter the code to him again that's oh
and E PE l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter
the code tama check out to receive $100
off any accessories including the shoes
that you will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep I recently moved into a new home
and when I needed beds where did I go
and went to helix and I paid for them
with my own monies I tried all sorts of
mattresses some of you saw me soliciting
feedback and ideas on social media I
tested a ton and I ended up on helix
they offer mattresses personalized to
your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars so
check it out helix sleep calm
forward-slash Tim and you can take their
very simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz to get started that's a diagnostic
and they can build your mattress from
there and ensure that it is something
you will absolutely love the quiz helps
determine the type of mattress that is
best for you by asking all sorts of
questions about your sleep behavior such
as if you tend to line your back side or
stomach as well as your body type for
couples they can even personalize each
side of the mattress their customer
service is phenomenal my assistant my
researcher I had them all test helix and
the customer service is really
outstanding the mattress arrives within
a week and the shipping is completely
free you can try the mattress then for a
hundred nights and if you're not happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund so check it out to personalize
your sleep experience visit helix sleep
comm forward slash Tim and you can get
$50 off of your custom mattress so check
it out
helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
diggety diggety diggety hello ladies and
gentlemen this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show aka perhaps tribe of
mentors I have two podcasts and this
applies to both my guest today we're
going to explore her lessons
tribulations obstacles overcome and so
much more how to survive on tiny roles
in New York City while sleeping on
couches Bosma st. John she is the chief
brand officer at uber and until June
2017 she was a marketing executive at
Apple music after joining the company
through his acquisition of beats music
where she was the head of global
marketing there's so much to this story
in 2016
billboard named her executive of the
year and fortune included her in their
40 under 40 list Fast Company has also
included Bosma on its list of the 100
most creative people there's so many
details that we can dig into you can say
hi to her Bozeman st. John Bo zom a on
Twitter and Instagram at bad ass buzz bo
z and I think I'll just keep it at that
I took so many notes in this
conversation there's so many things that
I am going to use and I hope the same
for you so without further ado please
enjoy my wide-ranging conversation with
Bosma st. John Bo's welcome to the show
thank you so much you are perhaps in the
last six months the most requested
podcast guests by all of my friends on
the internet and I'm so glad that we
finally were able to find a time to jump
on the phone and have a conversation so
thank you for making the time yes well
thank you for having me I don't know if
I should be scared about being you know
the most requested or I do this I don't
know how to react to that I I think I
think flattered is fine i don't i def i
I don't know if I wouldn't say flattered
is a necessity but you certainly don't
have to be scared and plus as far as I
can tell you don't really get very
afraid of things and will might come
back to that so yeah
come back to that and I thought that in
typical Tim sort of momentum nonlinear
fashion we'd actually just start with
something that is as a segue from being
the most requested on Twitter so this is
your pinned tweet and I wanted to hear
the background on this so it's a quote
from Nietzsche it's you must be ready to
burn yourself in your own flame how
could you rise anew if you have not
first become ashes why why is that your
pin tweet and what does it mean to you
you know I have I have always felt very
much aligned to the Phoenix you know the
thought of rising from ash that things
seem to always burn you know burn really
really bright like in some sort of like
destructive you know fatalistic extreme
fashion for me it has always been that
way
you know when I was five my dad was in
politics in Ghana which is where my
family lived and there was a coup d'etat
which meant that the government was
overthrown by the military and my dad
along with all of his colleagues were
thrown into political detention you know
my mom had to escape with me my two
younger sisters and she was pregnant
with my youngest sister and we had to
you know escape to Washington DC for
under political asylum and you know even
starting from there if it has always
felt like you know crazy dramatic things
happen and then I have to start over you
know but the starting over is always
better than whatever I came from and so
I have never been afraid of the fire
let's call it and so when I read that
and by the way I only read that recently
I think was like two years ago or
something it just just so struck a chord
anything I just always wanted to see it
you know to remember it because even
though life has sort of patterned it
that it's you know it's way with me I I
just wanted to be able to always
remember
it's great quote and it seems like in
some ways this is another thing we'll
come back to and I typically don't lose
track of the stuff I say that I'll come
back to so we will we will get back to
be in some ways you had these life
experiences which resemble the phoenix
rising from the ashes and now you oh it
seems in some capacity you're almost
seeking out experiences where you can
help the phoenix rise from the ashes
which is cool to just certainly to watch
and i've been looking forward to this
conversation for some time but i want to
rewind the clock and go back to i
suppose it may be there were a few
locations in between but you could tell
me from ghana you end up in DC and then
from from that point at least around age
12 you moved to colorado is that right
well so I was born in Connecticut my dad
was getting his PhD or two babies and
ethnomusicology and anthropology he'd
come from Ghana as a Fulbright Scholar
and I was born six months before he
received his degrees so right after he
received them we went back to Ghana
which then you know he got into politics
and we had to leave when I was five we
were in the US for about a year or so
before my both my parents wanted to move
back to Africa but we couldn't go to
Ghana so we moved to nairobi kenya and
we were in arabic enniaa for about two
years
and then of course because Ghana was
calling him so much um my dad decided
that we should move back to Ghana we
were there for another two and a half
years or so before you know realizing
that things weren't really gonna work
out there you know politics wasn't
wasn't working out for him there and
then he made the brilliant decision that
we should move to Colorado Springs
Colorado because what more diverse you
know places to move your for African
daughters your wife than there how did
you what why Colorado this is this is
the I've been so curious about this why
was Colorado
the decision oh it's like I mean I love
Colorado I think it's a cool stage by
the way I'm so glad
but why Colorado why Colorado there's a
number of things first
he really did like Colorado I think he
really loved you know the open spaces
and the mountains and neither my parents
are afraid of cold which i think is a
stereotype about Africans or something
that like you know you must not go
someplace cold or something but neither
of them were afraid of it but my dad
would also wanted to help out
international students who were studying
in the US because he had been one and
there was a company organization out
there called International Students
Association for our international
students international students
association yeah that's right and they
were charged with basically helping to
support international students the u.s.
who are studying to get their graduate
degrees and they were based in Colorado
and so he was like oh yeah that sounds
like a good idea let's just go there
I'll do that
these girls will grow up in this you
know beautiful location will be in
America they'll get a great education
and we'll just build our life here I
don't think he he really was thinking
about the whole diversity thing though
when we moved there some of the main and
take will not take aways I mean it
sounds like taking a Freshman Seminar or
something but what did you gain from
that experience of being in Colorado or
what did you learn about yourself or
others I mean I have read accounts for
instance of I guess it was your mother
were refusing is too strong a word but
choosing not to make pizzas for Friday
nights I suppose it was when people
would come over and instead we would
make traditional dishes so I mean you
were set in such a well different
environment right compared to what you
had experienced what did you what were
some of the takeaways and learnings from
that yeah you know it's so interesting
because I have because I moved around so
much as a kid the moving to Colorado
wasn't really that true
attic you know I think that you would
think about it in people you know like
sort of clutch their prose and like oh
my god
you were this like dark-skinned African
girl who moved to very white Colorado
that must have been awful you know
and the truth of matters that I had
moved around a lot I was a new kid all
the time
and so that didn't bother me that much
however I think culturally it was
difficult for me because in the moving
around we'd always been in what I feel
like were very international cities you
know places where there was a community
of like let's call them expats and so
the feeling was always very cosmopolitan
you know that people moved around they
had at least some idea of where you came
from you know and there was some
appreciation for difference and I didn't
find that at first when I got to call it
Oh Springs you know that there was not
an appreciation of anything that was
different from people who grew up in
Colorado and that was difficult you know
because I wanted to you know fit in
obviously it was 12 I wanted to make
friends I wanted to feel quote/unquote
normal and you know now of course I can
look back at it and be very thankful
that my mom yeah refuses actually a good
work because I don't you haven't met my
mother but she's refusing refused to buy
pizza you know yeah she would say listen
like you go to their house they feed you
their food they come to our house we
feed them our food like she it was just
there was no argument you know but also
was like things like speaking our native
tongue in the house you know is like she
had no problem again like you know
having my my little teenage friends over
and speaking to me in our native tongue
oftentimes addressing them in our native
tongue even though she speaks three
languages you know including English
very well what is what is your native
tongue fonti fun to you yeah it's a
dialect in Ghana yeah so anyway it's
just you know she just she she is has
been instrumental and in
you know sort of acceptance of even
myself you know that there was the
things that I learned from that moment
where that you know it's okay it really
is okay to be different and be vastly
different and to celebrate those things
you know not to be ashamed of it not to
hide it not to try and be something else
because it's not the norm and that
that's okay you know even just even that
simple what seems like a simple thing
has been so instrumental in my life and
even as I sit here today you know that I
am never afraid of being the odd man out
you know because I feel very comfortable
in that space well I think when I think
of you one of the adjectives that jumps
to mind is is bold and I'm I and I'm
curious
I'd love to dig in to where that comes
from maybe it comes primarily from your
mom but for instance you seem to really
aggressively and I mean that in a good
way
pursue certain leadership positions
rights and that started pretty early as
I understand it so captain of the
cheerleading squad and the track is that
right now yes I ran for student council
yes I lost which is okay can't get all
bad a thousand and a men and on and on
and on and on so how did you develop
that and are your sisters all that way
as well yeah I think it's a I think it's
in the genes you know both my parents
are very bold people like I told you my
dad was you know he ran for political
office he had no problem like moving his
family around the world you know making
probably decisions that other parents
wouldn't make you know my mom has always
been very bold you know in the way that
she in her fashion in the way that she
raised us in her speech and her
directness that those are all things
that I just grew up hearing and knowing
that there was never any fear that I
wasn't gonna be able to do something and
my parents never they would never allow
me you know to feel like I wasn't able
to do something and so that fearlessness
or both
or going for the big thing has has been
taught as well as it's my nature you
know because those are the kind of
people I come from it's a couple of
questions what were your best events in
track oh I was a sprinter so the hundred
the 200 the four by one and the hundred
hurdles were my were my races I loved oh
definitely not do any workouts with you
number one I will tear I'll tear all all
the hamstrings and now the what in the
case of say the student council were you
lost what would your parents say to you
after something like that
yeah I'm just if you can recall or even
Mary yeah all right so what would they
say to you after something like that
it's the same thing that they say to me
after anything that is that I consider a
failure you know first of all again both
of them very direct and in a I describe
it so I keep on theater like
stereotypically African you know like my
dad is very harsh in the way that he
speaks you know like he's like if when
so for instance when I lost it came home
he's like her and obviously he's been in
politics right so he feels like oh you
should naturally you should win you know
run a campaign you win yeah
and so I come home and he's like yeah
how do you go I'm gonna do the accent
because yeah sure yeah how do you go I
was like yeah so I didn't get it he's I
didn't get what not not one position and
you didn't get president you didn't get
vice-president you didn't get assembly
man you didn't get a council man you
didn't get anything nothing at all you
know and I'm like no like like no
position at all he's like you should do
it next year build up your audience and
do it next year you know it was always
that way it was like there was no time
for tears okay fine just do it next year
right you know it's like I don't even
know why like this is not this is not a
question this is not an option for you I
don't care if you don't think you want
to do it again you're gonna do it next
year
so did you do it next year
I sure did and I lost again and then
what did he show the same thing yeah oh
oh oh is that the flea thing is that
like I literally had to graduate from
high school before he stopped harassing
me about running for City Council you
know it's like I had to leave school
like that was the only solution you know
he would have made me run until like
there was no one left to vote you know
people make me do it again and over them
also you can be completely what about
your mom
oh my mom my mom is definitely more
nurturing you know she's the one who's
like oh well maybe you know we should
figure out a new campaign you know or
maybe we should make something you know
like she's always very solution oriented
as well but in a softer way and so she
was you know she allowed me to sulk and
feel sorry for myself you know and and
then he'll make you feel give you the
pep talk you know to make you go back
out but also very solution-oriented to
say okay we're gonna do this again we're
just gonna try some new things yeah no
no so this is uh this is an odd segue
but we're gonna go there anyway uh is it
true that you brought jay-z to campus at
one point was a high schooler college
dude it was college at Wesleyan yeah I
think it was like it had to be 1996
probably right maybe not maybe 95
because it was really early so yeah so I
got to college I was pre-med and I
although I was I was good in the
sciences and math the things that really
made me you know like live or excited
you know the things were exciting to me
were the arts you know music and dance
and art and all that and writing and
that kind of thing and so my outlets
were to join all of the like social
clubs that would allow me to you know
express myself in that way and so for me
one of those places was like the you
know the the student the committee for
like african-american development I
think osoto was called or the Black
Student Alliance that
in other places it's called and one of
the things we always did was you know
fundraisers right because you needed the
money to put on the show to do today and
I joined the committee for like musical
engagement especially it I don't even
know what that means
very I mean it's very professional and
so yeah and so we we had a campus radio
station I didn't have a show but I had
all my you know all the friends who were
doing the radio stations and who had or
who had the radio programs radio shows
and had the opportunity to bring other
people you know bring people as guests
to campus and one of those guys knew
jay-z's people and so we were throwing
you know like I think it had to be like
the fall the you know that's the fall
dance or something like that and you
know just talk to him about all the
different options and I remember that he
had this like a collection of CDs you
know it was like the they called back
then it was like you could order them
for like 99 cents do you know well I
know you're telling him I was like the I
want to say the random house clearing
something rather but I'm not getting no
Columbia House records it was something
like that where you could get like 12
CDs for like a dollar or whatever right
right
it was definitely some sort of scheme
and he had like hundreds of these things
and we're you know he's showing me like
his favorites and jay-z was one and I
wasn't really familiar jay-z because
even though I like I said I went to you
know high school in Colorado
I definitely you know swung more West
Coast like gangsta rap than I did East
Coast hip-hop and so I wasn't as
familiar with Jay but I was determined
that if these set of people wanted to
see you know East Coast rapper then
jay-z was gonna be the best and so we
were gonna go get him so literally was
like phone calls we like called the
management team I don't even know how we
got the phone number to be honest with
you Carl
we made a pitch yeah and he came to
campus he came to campus and we were in
the cafeteria that's where we set up
two dollars at the door because you know
it's like when you give a free concert
usually I learned that actually then
that when you do things for free people
don't show up if you make a little bit
of value they you know they will show up
so it was two dollars at the door it was
not very packed in there which is so
unfortunate J was not happy with that
but we threw it we threw it and now I
can say I did it now how big was he at
the time was he was he it's hard for me
to rewind the tape yeah to think back to
that point was in other words was that
in your mind a huge get or it was like
oh cool we got this guy who is very
well-known on the East Coast but dot dot
or was it as big I get as I'm
envisioning in my head you know what it
I think at the time we thought it was a
big gap because he was well-known in New
York or in the tri-state area and we we
wanted a name that people would
recognize so it wasn't like he was
unknown you know but he wasn't the
international superstar that he
obviously that he is now and so to us we
were really excited we we knew he was
and we were excited to have him but
Wesleyan is not is not a you know a
diverse College either so or wasn't then
anyway and so the is just called a
target audience was not big enough to
fill the cafeteria that we had plant
what was do you remember your pitch on
the phone do you remember any of the
wording or anything yes I know that's a
long time ago but I'm just I'm always
curious yeah because I suspect I mean
you're you are a writer I mean I view
you as that I mean you're very good at
word smithing and it strikes me that
people who get good at deal making it
usually start or very often not usually
because you can develop a later but very
often I get a lot of practice in early
writes yeah yeah so if you have to give
good phone
yeah figure out certain approaches to it
so that you don't get hung up on in the
first 30 seconds
well let's here I'll tell you what a la
I'll bring up another example of
negotiation maybe we can edge into it
that way so you mentioned East Coast
West Coast
so we'll just in passing mention we
don't have to spend a lot of time on
this but that you ended up teaching a
class on Tupac right right in your
senior in all your spare time even
though you were pre-med and and doing
all these various things what I'm really
curious about is something that I read
in the New York Times and it says she
got into medical school but Lobby to her
parents for a year-long sabbatical and
then and then you said they agreed which
was their mistake now I don't know your
parents others what I've read but I'm
like okay I'm just thinking in my mind
what that conversation might have been
like so could you walk us through a why
did you want to take a year-long
sabbatical and then B how did you pitch
it or what was that like oh my gosh well
you know I think the art of the pitch is
always about enthusiasm you know it's
like it doesn't really matter what you
say as long as you're really excited
about what you're saying that people
often then will give you the benefit of
the doubt they really will write you
know it's like they and I along with the
with the jay-z concert I don't remember
exactly what I said but I know I was
enthusiastic about it you know and I
made the outcome sound probably really
good I'm sure that there was some
benefit and the same thing with my
parents you know my dad was very much oh
when I was a kid I was I was really good
in sciences and math and you know coming
from Colorado there were not a lot of
you know black girls or young women who
were science and math nerds who also won
the cheerleading team you know going to
college is they would just learn a lot
of numbers of us and so I found myself
in a probably the enviable position of
having my choice of places to go and
getting into programs that you know
we're looking obviously for diversity
but
so somebody like me who just didn't
appear to be the normal stereotypical
probably pre-med student and I don't
think you're the normal stereotypical
anything from from what I from what I
can tell but my my parents were so proud
you know of the fact that I was going to
be a doctor because for them you know
not only like politics and academic
academic SAR really important but you
know becoming a doctor an engineer or a
lawyer
were the three professions that they
felt would be acceptable you know for
their daughters and so becoming a doctor
was what needed to happen you know and
so yeah I graduated pre-med but I knew
in my heart that I just I knew I didn't
want to do that forever and or be a
doctor forever and I just didn't know
how else to push that back until I could
figure out what I actually wanted to do
cuz it wasn't like I was like oh I want
to go be a dancer you know I feel like
that would have been easier if I knew
what I want to do I just had no idea I
was like no I like these arts but I
don't know what career that is and so I
have nothing to tell my parents that
like I'm not gonna be a doctor I'm gonna
do this instead there was just nothing
and so the conversation was I want to
make sure that I'm gonna go to school be
committed to it and graduate in the
amount of time that will be acceptable
to you I can't do that unless I've taken
time to really figure this out and that
was really my pitch like so the end
result was you know what I would the
paint the picture I was painting was
that I could go now and struggle right
because I'd be looking for other things
to satisfy me and I'd probably fail or I
could take a year get all of this
wildness out of me that word that worked
yeah partly chose the previous one they
were like yeah yeah go go like you know
or I'm sorry
because of course they'd be like go go
yeah yeah go get all that out of your
system and then go to school be serious
mm-hmm and yeah that was that was
definitely a mistake for them so so they
agree and then you step into this
sabbatical did you have plans for it
already or were you flying blind like
walk us through any of the milestones in
that in that first year I had no idea
what I was doing it you know what's
funny is like back to you a question
about being or thinking we started about
being scared I was scared you know I was
really scared I didn't know what I was
gonna do but the thing is that I knew I
was really smart and I knew I could like
hustle and so with those two things
armed with smarts and hustle my I had
one friend who was living in New York
and I always wanted to live in New York
and she was getting her master's in film
from Columbia and so she had a like a
graduate apartment with a roommate but
they had a couch and so basically I told
her and her roommate that if they would
allow me to stay on their couch for
three months while I figured out how to
get a job and my own place you know that
I would cook you know I would cook
dinner like every night so that was sort
of the trade-off and they agreed so yeah
I went to New York with no plan like I
really didn't know what I was gonna do
but I was I didn't have any money
because my parents were definitely gonna
not gonna finance this yes okay in New
York you're gonna have to figure it out
and there was this little Dominican spot
on the corner of 125th Street near
Columbia where Scott Floridita where
those a very kind older lady who kind of
took me under her wing you know she
she'd feed me man let me tell you she
treated me for free you know um yeah
she'd give me like a meal a day now hold
on a second I hate to interrupt but I
have to ask like how did that happen I
mean did you just walk
and charmer off her feet or yeah how did
that end up happening yeah I would go in
and at first it started in the morning
because honest I really didn't have any
money and so I wanted my money to last
so I would go in in the morning and they
were selling like fresh rolls for ten
cents and so I would buy the fresh roll
eat that I you know had coffee back at
the house with tea and so I would go
back to the apartment and that would be
literally like sometimes my meal for the
day yeah and so I went in every day and
she knew that I was coming in every day
but she knew I didn't have a job you
know so we just started making
conversation and very much I mean it's
very much in my personality to talk to
strangers I'm very curious about people
and so I asked sort of ton of questions
you know and then she started asking me
questions and I don't we just struck up
a friendship and eventually I confessed
to her that I didn't know what I was
doing and I was just here trying to
figure it out I was sleeping on my
friend's couch you know and she had a
lot of really great advice and one of
the practical ones she had lots of good
like life advice but unpractical one was
that her niece had signed up at a temp
agency and they would call her in the
morning and tell her where to go and she
was making good money doing that right
because it felt for me it was like I'm
making no money so any money just pay me
in rolls like I'm cool you know
but she you know gave me the number of
the temp agency and literally changed my
life you know cuz I thought the temp
agency they start sending me out on jobs
I started making some money I was able
to feed myself and then one day the
magic call came which was that Spike Lee
had fired his assistant and they needed
me to go answer the phones at his new
advertising agency that he had just
created on Madison Avenue 49th Street in
Manhattan and I went okay so I have a
bunch of questions that are probably
gonna drive my listeners nuts clear and
be like Ferriss you're asking the most
unimportant uninteresting questions
imaginable but you're cooking for your
friends yeah every night right what were
your good do you remember your go-to
meals oh yeah there's so my go-to meals
now
we go it's like some sort of starch
right so either pasta or rice we're my
my two that I like or potatoes every
once again but I don't like potatoes
myself so that a meat you know so I like
stews and soups
so chicken or beef or fish in like a
tomato based soup or tomato base to and
then a green that's this that was
usually oh it's so some variation of
that everyday do you have a favorite
green if you had to choose one or two to
have in your refrigerator as a staple
what would they be
oh maybe someone really like collard
greens now oh so good right collard
greens are so good they're hard to make
but they're once you know how to do it
it's they're so delicious and collards
can sit you know for some time so you
know become everyday you know yeah they
don't fall apart as much one just just
since I have food on the brain haven't
had much d6 I'll make a recommendation
if you get a a light fish like a cod or
tilapia you can cook it in almond flour
so you just kind of coat it in almond
flour and then you can make tacos using
the collard greens as the wraps one and
they're just amazing anyway this is a
very interesting recipe oh it's
fantastic okay I get some guacamole it's
it's killer so now okay I want to talk
about the your fresh roll connection and
the yaks life advice she gave you is
there do you recall any of the other
advice that she gave you besides the
very practical tactical recommendation
yeah yeah yeah you know was it was so
much even about her advice but the fact
that she was so encouraging you know
like I would go in there every morning
and she would just you know have the big
smile on her face and just say you know
so today is the day you know today's a
day like that that kind of advice you
know where like every day even if they
didn't happen yesterday she liked
today's it like it's it you know you're
gonna get it today
and she don't even know what the hell I
was trying to do you know but also just
you know things like she's just smiling
people he's smiling all the time you
know just stuff like that where you know
I feel like any sort of older
mom or grandma type of character would
tell you you know that like smiling
people be friendly you know today's a
day make it happen today
even if that kind of thing she was just
a more of an encourage or than anything
well I mean without the right state and
without the right optimism it's it's
hard to come up with the proper strategy
or put any of it yes into action right
so that's right yeah she's actually
right suspision see all right so I
alright so you're there and my my
understanding I have I do not know much
about this I just did a little bit of
homework and I wanted to get the real
story so I my understanding is that he
dropped a draft of I think it was
bamboozled in front of ya and said tell
me what you think of this okay God he
told you to read okay this is even
better got it alright so this makes it
more that's really important okay so now
tell us tell us what happened after that
no just just as people hear this story
that difference is really really
important please read this is definitely
because I was answering phones let's
remember I was answering phones I was
doing nothing else my answering folks
that's a lot I was getting coffee I was
cleaning up dirt like I was doing
whatever needed to be done right and
yeah he just he had just finished
writing bamboozled he was about to start
like you know casting and principal
photography and he yeah he was walking
by my little reception desk and he
dropped in he was like hey read this cuz
actually he knew when I'm gone in a few
a few times that he'd made small talk
with me he knew that I I loved to read
and that I wanted to write were two
things that I thought I wanted to do at
the time and so I think for him it was
just say you know like I just wrote
something here you read it you know but
what I heard was you should give your
thoughts on this and by farts I thought
he meant like mark it up so
I took my nice and why I had a red pen I
will never know like I cursed myself to
this day like why did you pick up a red
pen of all things like why not a blue
pen or a black pen red is very
judgmental
that is a very judgmental pen you know
and I read it and made notes and
corrections and oh just made yeah lots
of markups in his manuscript and then he
came he came back like you know it
wasn't the next day but it was like
maybe three days later which by there
was was quite a feat cuz bamboozled was
a is a hard script to read I don't know
if you've seen the film but it's it's
very heavy and he came back and he was
like what you think and I handed him I
handed it to him and he's like open like
he looked kind of infuse he opens it up
he's like flipping through the pages
like you marked up my script I was like
you know I was like one of those moments
just like oh oh my god I don't know what
I did wrong you know and he just he just
shook his head and just walked off and I
thought for sure I was fired that's
right I just started packing my bags
like where's my purse let me just go
ahead and get my purse right now because
I'm out of here
but he came back out like you know I'm
sitting there like literally shaking off
I think I really need to pee as like my
armpits are itching I'm like oh my god I
can't even and he he left me like that
for like an hour and a half he comes out
he's like you made some good notes oh
okay okay
and it was literally that moment where
he was like you know what you should
stick around he was like I think we
could find a job for you here and
literally that's how I got my permanent
job there so out of that crazy moment I
believe he realized my potential man
what a great story so a friend of mine
you may have bumped into him or heard of
him but you should meet him at some
point he's in the Bay Area named Duvall
Rafa Conte
a fantastic entrepreneur and investor a
good good friend of mine and and he is
said I'm paraphrasing here but
along something along the lines of if I
always did when I was qualified do I'd
be pushing a broom somewhere and it's
just such a great such and such a great
story because there are so many examples
of moments like this when I look back at
the stories of folks have had on the
podcast it's like just doing that one
extra thing that you may not be
qualified to do even if it's accidental
right takings I should've right okay now
if if we look forward than from that
point are there were there any
particularly critical decisions that
were sort of forged your career over the
over the next few years following that
incident they look back to yeah I mean I
think so you know I really loved that
quote that you just said because it is
true you know it's like at one point I
was doing really well with Spike
you know I gotten promoted a few times
and I was looking around thinking
because what he was really doing was now
what we call like the pop culture
marketing right or consumer engagement
but at the time it wasn't called that
and what I felt was like oh this is easy
to me you know I can do this I need
something that will make people pay
attention to me and know that I'm smart
so I was like oh let me go sign up for
some pharmaceutical advertising like a
pharmaceutical advertising job you know
because that's hard you know that it's
really really difficult to to execute
and I lasted like three months there
which by the way also led me to
understand that of course I'm capable
you know of course it's like if I didn't
push myself that way I wouldn't have
then made the next jump right knowing
that okay I'm smart enough to do this
but this is not what I want to do I want
to get back to the things I do know how
to do and make them better and to me
those are some of the more critical
moments where it's like it feels like
failure but it's actually helping you
turn
helping you to put a finer point on what
you actually know how to do or what you
should be doing and there's been you
know several several times like that
where I've felt like you know maybe
stretching with something that I wasn't
quite sure I could I could reach that
bar but I was gonna fake it anyway right
so you know it's like when I at one
point after I left spikes agency I went
to Pepsi and after a few years there I
quit and took a job at a fashion company
called Ashley Stewart and if you don't
mind me asking why did you quit I quit
because god man I'm telling you like I
quit for the most ridiculous reason
sometimes I quit because I was a brand
manager and you know there was a very
specific way that Pepsi organized its
marketing marketing team right it was
like you had a class everybody was
promoted you know or not you had you
know just the particular set of
responsibilities he couldn't really
stretch outside of those and it just
wasn't I was just like oh my god if I
stay here I'm just gonna be some you
know like middle management person with
nothing you know no excitement I just
didn't feel like that was the thing for
me and they're not that there's anything
wrong with that just wasn't for me I
wanted to do more and also I had already
begun to what I would call experiment
with my look today I really didn't want
to look like my colleagues and I knew
that I didn't have to and so I'd already
started to experiment and people would
make comments all the time you know like
about whatever I was wearing literally
every day I felt like I was like walking
a runway every day cuz I would walk into
the office be like what she got on today
you know and so people would say things
like well why do you work here you
should work in a fashion company and
mind you I had no idea about the
business of fashion at all zero idea but
I knew I had obviously the gold standard
and marketing at the time which was this
Pepsi you know pedigree
in marketing and the small company as I
mentioned Ashley Stewart which was based
in Secaucus New Jersey I was looking for
the head of marketing because they were
trying to turn around the brand I'd also
just had my daughter and the brand was
I'm really targeted towards plus-sized
women of color you know to like you know
fashion was print you know like zebra
print and gold and like LeMay and things
like that it wasn't the like a you know
competitor who was like you know tan
clothes and black and grays and I'd you
know gain some weight with with the
pregnancy of my with my pregnancy and I
just felt like I wanted to change the
way that women were portrayed or at
least plus-size women were portrayed and
it felt like the right thing to do so
without any experience at all I was like
oh yeah I'm gonna go do that plus it was
a team and it was the first time I would
be the head of anything you know so I
was like oh I want experience as a
leader to run my own team I have this
awesome marketing background and I am
super cute like why can't I do it I'd
understand yeah I went and again I
failed in like a year by it by a year I
was done it was over what was the what
was the cause of the failure Oh what
were the factors man there were many
factors one I didn't know when the hell
I was doing let's just start there no
but it was as I bit off too much you
know I just now looking back on my what
the hell was I thinking you know it was
like at this I bit off more than I could
chew it was both the fact that or are
those a few reasons one it was a pretty
big team and I'd never run a team that
size before and leadership is something
that you grow into you know you're not
you don't just run in and do it you know
it's like you've got to build it you
know you got to understand people you
have understand how what your management
style is like you know that's as
important as the people you're managing
how to manage different types of people
and different types of personalities how
to motivate people you know and then
yeah the simple basics of like I didn't
know anything about merchandising or
about store turns and with
out that kind of knowledge I wasn't as a
I wasn't as efficient to my business
partner as I could have been you know so
I had I brought all this wealth of you
know knowledge about base you know the
foundations of marketing and you know
email campaigns and photoshoots and you
know getting models together and the
look and feel and partnerships with
different companies but I didn't
understand the basics of fashion you
know and how the business turns and so
how could I be a good contributor a good
business partner to my colleagues I just
couldn't
and so yeah about about I would say
about nine months into it I was like
yeah you know what this ain't gonna work
but I didn't want to admit failure and
so it was somewhat of a relief to when
they came to me and they're like do you
like what you're doing they're like I
think I'm good at what I do just not
here I just grab my things and go oh man
and how did how did did beats enter the
scene yeah you're hitting like all the
points so I back to Pepsi after my
Ashley stewarding experience which was a
much better situation for me by the way
because I went back knowing that I
didn't want to do traditional brand
management but that I was really good at
the pop culture stuff and so we created
a new group called the music
entertainment group which meant that I
was doing all the deal-making for all of
the brands in the you know Pepsi
portfolio across all entertainment types
and so all of the deals were coming
through me and I was able to really do
some fun things towards the end of or
the middle of 2013 my husband who I've
been married to for almost 10 years was
diagnosed with cancer and I was really
at the you know it just hit us at a time
when we were both really high on our in
our careers right because I had I'd
really found my stride and what I felt
at corporate America but in marketing
with this you know music and
entertainment more
getting team we just come off like this
big you know show for the Superbowl with
Beyonce and I was announced feeling
myself I was like I am just the best
like nothing can take me down you know
and my husband Peter was also doing
really well he was in advertising well
he was a producer and we were both doing
really well you our daughter was four we
had our low family and when he was
diagnosed it was just such a blow to us
and unfortunately neither of us are you
know strangers to cancer are both of our
mothers are cancer survivors breast
cancer survivors and they both you know
receive treatment and radiation and
chemo and all of that surgery and so
like our first questions were you know
what happens look what's the plan what
do we do and there was no plan because
he had a very rare cancer and for him he
just wanted to be able to live his life
you know as passionately as he could for
whatever amount of time that he had left
and we found out really quickly that he
really didn't have a lot of time and so
six months after he is he was diagnosed
he passed away and that was in December
we just actually celebrated for years
that he's been gone and I I just I was
so lost you know in that I wasn't quite
sure what to do you know I we had been
living this very fast life he was so
much alive you know for me and that in
those last month's you know we were
trying to do everything that we could to
fit you know the rest of our lives into
those few weeks and one of the things he
made me promise along with with he was
also a very funny guy so he had a lot of
jokes one of them was that I I'm not
Catholic I'm not really religious I am
spiritual though but he was you know
born and raised Catholic and he promised
or he made me promise that I would raise
our daughter Catholic after he died or
he would haunt me was like a real threat
I'm afraid of ghosts and I was like you
can't hop me that's not fair it means
like yeah but I will though so you
better race for Catholic which you know
makes me laugh now because I really am
raising her that Catholic because I'm
really afraid but anyway that's a whole
nother story but part of that also and
what he made me promise was that you
know I wouldn't stop living life as as
you know deeply as you know again back
to the fire you know with as much fire
as possible that what we had learned in
the six months was that you really can't
take any day for granted you know and
that I would need to do that and so
after he passed away and I went back to
work because I you know I really do
enjoy my work and I find solace in it
and I find inspiration in it but I went
back to Pepsi and I just knew that I
needed to find something different to do
or something that something that would
like pull me into the future if that
makes any sense perfect sense and also
you know by divine intervention I met
Jimmy Iovine around the same time and
Jimmy had just launched beats music so
he already had Beats Electronics you
know headphones and speakers etc that
was already a booming business and so
but he had launched beats music which
was the first streaming platform from
music under him and he was looking for a
head of marketing and the funny thing is
of course like here I was like okay I
know big brand marketing I get it right
all of the important the foundational
stuff I also understand the music
entertainment space got I've been doing
it plus I needed emotionally something
to look forward to you know the feeded
to build the future and I needed
something again that factor like taking
risks and quitting jobs maybe sometimes
for stupid reasons I was like you know I
need to take another risk I need another
one I need something to make me feel
alive and so I told him I would move
across the country with my four-year-old
daughter this was three months after my
husband had passed away and I said okay
I will leave New York I'm gonna quit my
job leave New York and I'm moving to LA
to help you build this thing and I
took it as a sign that beach music was
born on my birthday so I was like pillow
this this makes all the sense in the
world I'm coming to LA and yeah so so
there's so many different things I love
to ask you about a few of the stories
that you just told before I do that
anyone listening who has not seen the
Defiant ones which is a miniseries
incredibly well done about dr. Dre and
Jimmy and the entire story of Beats and
certainly both of their lives
I highly highly recommend checking out I
had a number of questions and I thought
we could start with just to rewind the
clock this is this is certainly tying in
to your late husband but in tribe of
mentors thank you for being part of the
book by the way yes I said honor I asked
you about books that have had a large
impact on your life and you mentioned
Toni Morrison's Song of Solomon says I'm
wondering if you could just explain for
people why that has had an impact on
your life and what it's meant to you
yeah
oh man okay so Toni Morrison is one of
my favorite authors I've been reading
her since I was in high school and she's
a really hard author you know she
doesn't take it easy on her readers I
think he does like sometimes you know
you you write for the lowest common
denominator right but she doesn't she's
like you're gonna meet me at my level
and she's just a really difficult author
but I really love her storytelling that
was the experience of the
african-american and you know story the
african-american experience so well and
so richly so I really enjoyed her her
books but my favorite is Song of Solomon
and when I was in when I moved when I
finally got like my permanent job with
Spike it was in the Madison Avenue
building with DD B which is you know the
agency that basically Mad Men was was
created about right and Peter work
my late husband Peter worked at DDB and
they had a cafeteria at the bottom of
the building and so one day I'm standing
in line Peter by the way was a you know
six four of Italian descent just a big
dude with a big voice and a big
personality and a big gold chain which
sounds really stereotypical but he
really did wear like the gold chain and
so he's standing behind me in the line
by the way I don't notice him at all and
he which is hard to imagine cuz I just
describing this like this big person but
guess what I'm like a big personality -
so screw that you know what I mean right
anyway so he said behind me and you know
he's trying to drop some lines you know
like pickup lines and whatever I'm just
like this dude just needs to like quit
you know turn around and he's like I've
been coming down here to try and catch
you you know I would I would love to
take you out sometime and I was like or
no he said he said I would love to get
to know you better and I was like all
right if you want to get to know me
better you should read Toni Morrison's
Song of Solomon and then we can talk
about it and I walked away right
thinking like good there there we go got
rid of him you know but literally like
three weeks later he finds me in the
cafeteria again and he's like I read the
book and I was like no that's a that's
actually impossible I don't believe you
but okay you know what we can have a
coffee we can talk about it so we sat
down for coffee and he knew so much
about the characters that obviously the
plot lines we have such a rich
discussion and it was such a beautiful
moment for me because I was like wow
okay you know when somebody is is really
when someone is really interested
everybody really wants to get to know
you they're gonna do whatever it is that
it takes to get to know you the bar was
raised so high you know and then it was
raised high here because then for my
birthday which was about a month later
by then we'd been dating he painted a
picture of characters from the book
served me for my birthday
and I knew then I was like this guy's
everything you know if he is willing to
get to know me on my terms on my level
even though it's a high bar and he's
gonna jump it and
and go the extra step of being creative
about how he presents it back to me in a
new way that was that was going to be it
such a great story yeah that's it that
dude brought his AGame
that's that's a serious I have the
painting hanging in my daughter's room
now and the book that I gave him still
sits on my bedside so I'd love to follow
that up with a question about I suppose
grief and what helped you through the
grieving process me were there any
particular realizations or resources or
pieces of advice or anything that that
helped you yeah throughout that process
yeah you know it's amazing the the part
about our story that I don't often talk
about actually I've never talked about
so you got to excuse me because I'm I
get emotional
no problem is that before he was
diagnosed we were actually separated we
were you know it was just a difficult
time and like I said we were both moving
so fast and our career things were
really poppin and I think we just
stopped communicating properly so we
were separated and I really you know
didn't think that we would get back
together you know but I just thought you
know what relationships end and you know
that was a time of life and other than
that right and then he got sick and I
realized that you know you only get
these chances at this type of love if
maybe once you know like they're very
lucky get it once and I had it and so
for me it was a real moment of reckoning
you know to understand that you know
love like that doesn't come around and
to appreciate it and that love like that
not only doesn't come around often and
to appreciate it but that it can last
after the physical you know and after he
passed away it was for me really
understanding what it means to
forgive yourself you know like regret
and feeling terribly about maybe angry
words you said or you know taking
someone for granted or taking love for
granted it just changed my whole
perspective and for me the grief was not
even just about just losing him but also
forgiving myself you know for having
lost precious time that I didn't need to
lose that I chose to lose and that I
would never do that again you know and
so for me the grief wasn't just about or
healing wasn't just about getting over
and I'm using air quotes because there
is no getting over you know but it was
about learning the lessons from just
what I never watch repeat again you know
if it's like if I'm blessed enough to
ever find that kind of love again I will
never take it for granted you know and
and I think that's part of the healing
is that understanding what is really
important what's important to us was
important in making us happy and making
us feel satisfied that things can change
but that we should always always always
appreciate you know the the greatest
gifts that were given and I will never
forget that thank you for that I that
also hits home for me and in a few ways
it fortunately I've never I have
suffered the loss of family members and
and loved ones and best friends but
never a partner like that but the two
things that have historically been I'm
getting better but historically been
very big challenges for me are a
forgiving myself for anything and be
running maybe a little too hot in the
anger department yeah so what I'd love
to to hear from you because you're such
a high functioning individual but you
mentioned you know with the letting go
at least this is what I heard
of letting go of anger maybe as as an
emotion and forgiving yourself what it
what has helped you to modulate those
two things so to beating yourself up and
or just the anger piece because I think
what I see very often certainly myself
is that and I'm not saying this is you I
don't want to project but like people
who are very kind of aggressive ask for
forgiveness not for permission go getter
types very frequently also have some
collateral damage from both of those
things yeah yeah so I've tried to work
no I haven't tried I have worked very
hard on I'm trying to recognize that
those aren't always the best fuels
uh-huh yeah and ways to approach things
but what how how is your thinking about
say anger or self forgiveness change
what have you found helpful to have any
exercises or or phrases that you revisit
anything like that well it's interesting
because you're right I you know I I
would agree that you know folks who are
high functioning in this way run hot in
a lot of different ways yeah you know
and for me anger is one that I think
before either I kind of see see myself
like before Peter died and after Peter
died you know and before he died I was
definitely quick to anger
you know impatient you know unforgiving
it's probably a good word you know
[Music]
always demanding you know I expected
everything and I expected everything to
go well too by the way
cuz it had quite frankly I mean you know
things have been tough sometimes and as
we talked about the Phoenix and the fire
and all that stuff but I always found a
way through and so I was an MIT me
arrogant is a good word to all of those
words to describe the way that I was and
then something totally uncontrollable
you know an event so catastrophic and
traumatic that was outside of my control
and all of a sudden it just knocked me
down a peg or two
you know maybe three or four and coming
back from that has been all of this
learning you know about not running so
hot all the time because really it's
useless yeah you could still get a lot
of things done without having to leave
so much chaos in your wake for sure that
you know there's an opportunity I'm not
saying you never get angry I still get
angry you know things happen I'm still
impatient I want things to happen like
today all the time but knowing that I
can't damage others based on my anger
you know because then you have to fix
that and you have to go back and you
know correct those things and sometimes
that's more difficult to do than if you
hadn't made the mistake in the first
place first you know so understanding
that you know not everything gets done
through anger and you know like the fire
and screaming but that you can get a lot
more done when you're not that way you
know when you're peaceful and again not
that like I don't get angry but it's
just that I unwind it much easier now
and you know when some of those like
simple things really do help me it's
kind might sound corny but be walking
away they're counting to five the like
thinking okay let me think about this a
different way like how else could I get
this done you know that the conversation
with myself really really really really
really helps like the pause because like
I'm one of those like I it's like I take
it actually does take me a long time to
get angry but was like once I get angry
the fuse is lit and boof I'm like
firecracker right right so learning to
kind of slow myself when I could feel
that happening the walking away is
really important and those things have
really helped also make me reconsider
you know cuz when you do take time off
even walk away for a second oh let me
give you a good example psych you know
the fire back email woohoo man I've had
to like learn to not do that man I used
to be dangerous with that thing you know
it's like I would get something that
would just piss me
and then here right and then send yeah
and it usually caused a lot of damage
and now you know getting things like
that
I stopped maybe I'll write something but
I definitely don't send it
you know reread it reread it again you
know sometimes pray I'm like Lord just
save them from themselves because I'm
about to murder all of them okay fire
you know but then being able to you know
unwind that and think about different
ways to approach it doing it with the
honey instead of the brimstone is better
option yes for sure what one one
question that I found really helpful for
me personally because men have I created
some messes especially if I just haven't
had enough to eat and then I remember my
my effectively my chief marketing
officer on a few occasions has been you
know he sent me taxies be and it would
be something like wow you guys just came
out throwing haymakers huh yeah great
now I've spend the next like the rest of
the week doing political damage control
because I just didn't have enough peanut
butter in the morning or whatever it's
so stupid the question that I found so
helpful for me is you know what else
might this mean right and because
particularly with email like you might
read it like you're doing Disney
voiceovers in your head but you're using
like the the super villain from Lion
King or something is the voice for the
person who sent you this email and in
fact they were just like no very
matter-of-fact like smile on the face
this is this and but you had this this
horrible and instead of insinuation and
then then the gloves come off and it's a
big mess so yeah but another question is
related to while an answer that you've
given before this this was journalists
asked you it what advice you would give
your younger self and you can feel free
to modify this and maybe add to it but
what caught my eye was don't make
and con lists and I was I was hoping you
could elaborate on that and yeah maybe
give us an example or two from your
experience yeah well okay so that has
more to do with my feeling and it's very
personal you know to me it doesn't work
for everybody but what I have found in
my experience is that when I make Pro
loot pro and con lists it's usually
because I talk myself out of a good idea
or talk myself into a really bad one my
spirit knew right that my spirit knew
what to do but my head was like girl you
better make sure that's right you know
right and that internal dialogue because
you know I'm thinking well you know what
academically and logically let's think
through this yeah but my spirit always
knew what to do and more often than not
actually no let me every single time
that I did not listen to what my spirit
was telling me it was wrong even if I
rationalized to myself whether it was a
job to take or a relationship or a
business deal every single time and I
think the other thing is that for me you
know learning to trust that and call
whatever you want spirit got inner voice
you know there are lots of words for it
learning to trust that has been a real
process I'm still doing it now you know
where it's like I have to have a reason
you know it's like okay brain just shut
off like I don't have to rationalize
this it doesn't have to make logical
sense I just don't like that and I'm
gonna do it you know and by the way
again and again and again and again and
again I have proven myself correct that
later on I find out like oh that person
was a total ass yep you know or like
that job somebody else took it and mmm
look at them now you know like there has
been time and time and time and time
again when I've been right and I
couldn't have explained it to myself or
anyone else and so the pro economist has
gone by the wayside I just don't do that
anymore I try very much to them to just
listen to my spirit you know instead so
it's like if I if if ever the time that
it's like oh I'm gonna go into a quiet
you know because when you ride the phone
that's right you go into a quiet space
you think about the issue maybe you
write it down then you start writing
your list for me they said instead of
doing all of that
I really do go and you know get into my
quiet space and then just concentrate
you do I want to do what does this feel
like am I happy about this you know does
it make this bring me joy like those
type of questions usually I can answer
those yeah this is so important I really
like the wording you used also which I'm
I'm sure I'm gonna mangle right off the
bat but with what you said about using
whenever you use a pro and con list
you're either talking your way out of a
good idea or into a bad idea it's so
true I mean it's it's I I remember this
was a long time ago more than ten years
ago but I was dating this girl we dated
for about two years and I was agonizing
over this pro and con list for a
potential deal and looking at the deal
structure and the partnership and this
project that I really wanted to do or
thought I wanted to do and this just
went on for weeks right they're going
ago she ate her every little deal point
and so on and eventually she she was not
she was not involved in any negotiations
or deal structuring like this but
nonetheless at dinner one night she goes
do you trust this guy or not
and I was like uh no and she's like well
then don't do the deal and I was like
good advice and just just and again I I
to reiterate this is not necessarily
representative of everyone in the world
certainly and there are times when you
have to use data to make good decisions
but whenever I have had that little
spider sense tingling yes little gut
warning and I've ignored it 100% of the
time and just like you caught yourself
you know I'm inclined to hedge it and
say no like many times no a hundred
percent of the time it has ended up
being correct and it would have saved me
from a lot of pain and what I've noticed
for my for myself too is that it's taken
a lot of practice to start to listen to
that and
furthermore I've had for decades the
habit which is not constructive of
over-caffeinated and using a lot of Oh
caffeine and what I found is that that
is like hitting mute on for me my
ability to listen to that intuition or
that gut feel which is really based on
thousands or millions of years of
evolution like your body is trying to
tell you something right and right but
if I over caffeinated it's there's too
much noise and the signal doesn't get
through to talk to you about career
advice and to hear about may be bad at
best advice or worst advice that you've
received from whether it's meant mentors
or colleagues and we can we can kick it
off with with one that I read about
which maybe you can fact check or
clarify but they've a well-intentioned
female executive told you to never wear
red lipstick or red nail-polish is that
accurate or my god no that was a hundred
percent accurate all right what was the
rationale there and why why did it end
up not being good advice you know what's
interesting is that I feel like this is
we can put this in the category of when
people have good intentions you know
like you were talking about reading it
in the Disney character voice you know
reading it or she was saying it in a
very nice way I'm sure she was doing it
to help me but it was really came across
sinister and for me I really did listen
to it I accepted it I tried to implement
that the reason why I say it's the worst
advice I've ever received was that it
was damaging to me because she was
totally wrong that's the first thing but
also that there was this psychological
sort of reaction to that right which
meant that read to me where my it is one
of my favorite colors I do write wear
red lipstick red nail polish and it does
make me feel bold back to that word
again
and I think sometimes I use it as armor
and what that did was that strip me of
my armor no it stripped me of yeah that
like I could be bold and made me wonder
whether and I could show up as myself
all the time you know that perhaps I was
too bold and I was too loud and I was to
bits and I was to that and that's the
damage that it did you know and that's
mean when I look back it's not about
lipstick or nail polish really but it
was about trying to quiet this boldness
and making me wonder whether or not I
could appear as myself in any space in
any corporate space and be accepted and
so that was that was terrible clearly I
ditched that advice for good and and
definitely created my own rules but it
was really tough you know because
obviously I was well not obviously but I
did respect her and she was more
successful than I was and I wanted to be
successful and so when somebody who's
successful tells you to do something you
try to do it even when it damages you
yeah how did let's let's talk about good
advice who are people that you think of
in your career as important mentors
along the way if anyone comes to mind is
there is there anyone in particular who
really helped you to maybe think
differently or make better decisions to
hone you as a as a human being or as a
professional yeah I mean certainly I
could you know point to my early role
model slash mentors you know my parents
obviously when it when I started working
you know Spike Lee definitely you know
and his boldness and his what I would
call like not carelessness but he really
defied how people in you know his work
as his work and he doesn't care about
the criticism you know he's gonna create
the work that he knows should be seen
and that has certainly inspired me you
know that sometimes critics are just
people who can't see the world the way
you see it so who cares that is a great
way to put it yes right
a great way to put it yeah and along the
way there have been different types of
people who've come in and out you know
it's so funny cuz now when people are
like oh I want you to be my mentor you
know and I'm like but do you need me
right now you don't like me right now
though you know like you see me but you
might not need me you know you might
need somebody else at this very moment
because mentors are like friendships you
know some of them are long-lasting some
of them are for a season some of them
are from far away I've been inspired by
a lot of people that I don't know Kris
Jenner
you know Oprah even though I've I've
begun to know her recently which is
awesome you know Arianna Huffington who
has a real impact a significant impact
of my life right now but there have been
there have been lots of people along the
way that I have felt you know drawn to
because I want to not emulate that but
live more boldly or make different
decisions based on things I've seen that
they've been able to do what do you see
in just to take the last example Arianna
or what have you observed that is or
heard that has impressed you oh my god
she's she's a fascinating woman where
I've become friends with her over the
last several years along with her sister
but what's your hair has been like you
know what I learned from her it was it
same me present she is you know when
you're in a conversation with her or
hell when you text her she is so
responsive you know when I'm in her
presence and she is talking to me I
don't think that she's thinking about
anything else except whatever I'm
towards we're talking about you know
it's really it's a really important
quality and one that I have now taken on
to be more present in conversations you
know cuz you have your phone or you're
distracted you think about something
else you're like you know going on and
on whether it's in the work environment
or in a casual environment I'm I'm
trying to be more present so that I can
really hone in on what people are saying
and how I'm responding in
to them and it's been really really
fascinating to see her do that and how
much I appreciate it so I know people
would appreciate it when I do it you
know it's a good lesson it's you're so
right
I didn't I've noticed just how dramatic
the impact is when you're having if
you're having a conversation with
Arianna let's just say it's at a dinner
that she's hosting and she is a Jedi
Master of of hosting such things but
let's say there are 20 people when she's
talking to you even though many people
might be vying for her attention you
felt like you're the only person in the
room and her eye contact is also just
incredible and I was just thinking I
never really revisited this but when I
think about what I remember from those
conversations I remember a lot of the
detail of what we talked about but yes
even though other people at the dinner
were very impressive in various ways
they didn't have that same focus when we
were talking and I keep struggling right
now to think of really next to anything
that we spoke about it yeah she's really
she's very very present it's very it's a
really great lesson you know because I
think also you know Maya Angelou said
you know people rarely remember what you
said but they'll always remember how you
made them feel
and I have learned that from Ariana to
just and living that when I'm with her I
feel like she cares about me you know
cares about what I have to say is
responsive to what I'm saying I want
people to feel that way when they
interact with me know I want them to
feel like I care because I do and
sometimes I think it just comes across
long because you over here looking at
you know the notification that just came
on your phone you didn't mean to look
like you weren't paying attention you
know or like you're looking around the
room when they're asking you a question
but to maintain that eye contact be
present in the conversation not trying
to run off somewhere you know makes
people feel like you care and I do as I
want I want to bring that across well I
think it does come across and I know we
only have a little bit of time left but
I'd love to ask a few just a few
questions and just as we're going
through the the chapters of your life
for thus far I have to ask how did you
know that uber was the right next move
for you right right yeah man
you know that's it's like if there was
ever attention to write a pro and con
list it would have been when I when I
was gonna take the job at Hoover yeah
that would have been the moment you know
to write one but I still didn't do it so
I really came upon it because Arianna
I've been talking to Arianna about and
you know this was shortly after delito
birth she's on the board and we were
having tea at her apartment and I was
talking to her about what I would do you
know as a marketer I was working at
Apple of course and she was really
fascinated you know by what I was saying
and she suggested I talked to Travis
car-like who was a CEO at the time about
it and again I was just like oh ok well
I don't care it's fine you know and he
happened to be in LA so she you know
arranged for us to meet for an hour to
talk about it we ended up talking for 8
hours 8 hours my god 8 hours you know
just and and some of it was you know
education right me telling you know just
being like hey no you should really try
this after that and you know this is a
team and then but also like the human
connection of you know really
understanding what happened
oh why things happen and himself as a
human being you know and it was just
they were just so it was just a complex
conversation and I left the conversation
thinking man they've got a job to do you
know like hope they find somebody could
do it and then I am I in my very
comfortable Apple office over the next
few days and I was like [ __ ] I have to
go do it
look I have to go do it I have to leave
I've to leave I do it you know and it
was it was a combination of you know
this idea which of course now so many
people are talking about sexual
harassment and you know diversity issues
and discrimination etc and quite
honestly
I just feel I feel the real need to
contribute to the solutions you know
that I don't want to sit on the
sidelines and wait for somebody else to
fix it you know especially when it comes
down to these more sensitive and what
can be catastrophic challenges this is
not necessarily about saving a brand
this is about saving an ideal you know
that I want our industry I want my
future I want my daughter's future to be
changed I want it to be changed because
of this moment you know I don't want us
to be the same and so it says not to me
so when people say like well are you
gonna save the brand of uber I'm like no
that's not what I'm here to do you know
I'm here to save an ideal I'm here to
make sure that we never go backwards and
that we use this catalyst moment to
peles forward into a better community
and a better society and a better
industry and better work environments
that's it you know so and if the brand
gets saved along the way fantastic well
I think you for me you you highlight
it's the right expression the right
expression might be proactive
constructive dissent dissent isn't quite
the right word but if I look at the poll
quote at the at the top of your chapter
in tribal mentors which went completely
nuts online when when I put it up we
spend far too much time complaining
about the way things are and forget that
we have the power to change anything in
everything right and it reminds me of
something that I was also told I want to
say was Joseph gordon-levitt his really
smart guy which was you know it's very
easy to say it's very easy to say what
you're against yeah but it's important
to say what you're for yes and there's a
big difference right there's there's a
very big difference between trying to
build a better future versus trying to
tear down what causes you some type of
visual visceral negative they're
actually very different things
so how would you encourage people to
think about this I mean there there's
there are a lot of hot-button issues
there are a lot of things that need to
be fixed but there's also a lot of
complaining on the internet that as far
as I can tell there's very little to
actually yes fix things and repair
things correct
so if would you how can we steer the
ship in the right direction
if that's possible I mean what or how
would you encourage people change their
thinking so that they're more likely to
build as opposed to just simply destroy
an attack right you know it's it's wow
this is a this is a big one yeah yeah
for me well first of all I love that
that idea you know about encouraging
versus sort of tearing down Idol
destroying by the way I am very much a
fan of calling things out when you don't
like it yep you know making noise about
it but I want to cigar step further you
know it's not just about making the
noise but then how are we actively
changing the set environment right you
know for me that's it's very much like
you know yes the quote that's in your
book which again by the way thank you so
much for asking me to participate it was
really man by the way when I got it I
was like holy crap look how big this
book is this is amazing so many people
in here oh man it was like a party thank
you for being partners yeah but I really
I really am enamored by the idea that we
really can't change anything at all you
know and that each of us are responsible
responsible for the change you know I
said it before like even early on in my
career when we were when people would
talk about diversity numbers and the
lack of women and this so forth and so
on
and I would say but why are we looking
to the CEO to change the numbers you
know what about us like if you're not in
a position to hire it's like what can I
recommend
you know someone in a job that I see
open right when I am in a position to
hire can I hire from a diverse pool of
candidates you know when I do have a
seat at the table can i implement
procedures and processes to change the
dynamics of how our corporation or
organization looks you know that we must
we must do that you know the we have the
power to do that and that just sitting
back and complaining about things is not
it doesn't help anything and on the
other side of it you know I really do
think there's a lack of encouragement in
general these days yeah thank you you
know that when we see good things we see
great things let's applaud the hell out
of it yes no let's scream from the
rooftops when we see amazing things
happening hell I'm here for everybody
get surprised you know it's like if you
see even a small thing let's the pot
let's applaud it because I think that
the you know the the drumbeat and the
noise over great things can drown out
you know people who want to do bad or do
badly you know that when we are in a
position to celebrate the great things
that are happening are the good things
that are happening we encourage more of
it and so I want to see us do that more
you know I certainly do it I do it
myself you know I am always applauding I
brought my friends I bought myself yeah
myself on the back all the time because
I really do want to see more
encouragement of each other and of
humanity out here it's such an important
point I'm really glad you said that and
the positive reinforcement is really
really really important if you want to
change one person's behavior or if you
want to help catalyze a cultural shift
you can't just be smashing the dog on
the head with a newspaper for everything
I give it like there has to be some
element of shaping the behavior you want
with positive encouragement it's just
like based if you look at science you
look at evolution you look at yes
any any sort of observable phenomena
that that is a necessary ingredient you
can't just get it done by whacking
someone on the head because then it's
they'll just learn they'll develop some
type of learned helpful hopelessness or
opt out right which you see quite a bit
unfortunately right now has a lot of
people opting out of these conversations
completely and but if you if if in
addition to or instead of just getting
upset
you also get motivated right and sort of
be decide what you're for not just what
you're against I mean I do think like
you said you can you can change a lot
more than you would expect
and for instancing we mentioned Arianna
Huffington before one of her favorite
books is meditations by Marcus Aurelius
and so she has she and I have talked
about this because you can not only
change external circumstances right but
even if you change external
circumstances in some respect you you'll
never be totally in control of everyone
else's responses why you can cultivate
the ability in yourself to become more
emotionally resilient let's say a little
less hair trigger and that helps you to
be a more effective agent for change
well I want to let you get to your
evening this is this is so much fun for
me is there any ask just with the all
the people listening do you have any
final words suggestions or an ask for
the audience oh man that's a big one
thank you so much for having me by the
way this is this is so amazing and it's
been such a great conversation you know
I feel like we could keep talking for
hours oh yeah oh yeah I'll try to get me
TK a run for his money with our I know
we'll have a nine-hour conversation
exactly well you know what I am you know
as their great poet TLC would say I
ain't too proud to beg you know I'm not
too proud to beg for support you know
this is I am constantly need of support
you know
I think sometimes we see people
achieving and we think they have it all
figured out I have a lot of things
figure it out
but I do appreciate support you know I
am inspired by people I love to hear
about the great things that people are
doing but I also like to be encouraged
myself and so if you see me in the world
or you see me on social media I would
appreciate a word of encouragement and
that's what I ask
here here well like like your your moral
support
with the rolls in the mornings way back
in the day today is the day today is the
day and people can find you on twitter
instagram at badass bows that's bo z and
certainly can with with encouragement
and great interest watch how you
continue to build as the chief brand
officer of ready burn and is there
anywhere else that people can say hello
or should learn more about what you're
up to
yeah just yeah I'm pretty open on social
media so it's find me there engage
engage being an executive being a mommy
being a daughter being a friend
well I really appreciate you taking the
time this is so much fun for me and I'm
sure that my my my listeners will no
doubt seek you out online and if there's
anything I can do to help please do let
me know but but thank you so much for
carving out a little bit of your very
valuable time to have a conversation I
sincerely appreciate you today is the
day and for everybody listening as usual
you can find show notes links to
everything we talked about on tim dot
blog forward slash podcast where you can
find shown us for this episode in every
other episode
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favourite
new albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by helix sleep
I recently moved into a new home and
when I needed beds where did I go I went
to Keith woods and I paid for them with
my own monies I tried all sorts of
mattresses some of you saw me soliciting
feedback and ideas on social media I
tested a ton and I ended up on helix
they offer mattresses personalized to
your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars so
check it out blitz sleep calm
forward-slash Tim and you can take their
very simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz to get started at the diagnostic
and they can build your mattress from
there and ensure that it is something
you will absolutely love the quiz helps
determine the type of mattress that is
best for you by asking all sorts of
questions about your sleep behavior such
as if you tend to lie on your back side
or stomach as well as your body type for
couples they can even personalize each
side of the mattress
their customer service is phenomenal my
assistant my researcher I had them all
test helix and the customer service is
really outstanding the mattress arrives
within a week and the shipping is
completely free you can try the mattress
then for a hundred nights and if you're
not happy they'll pick it up and offer a
full refund let's check it out to
personalize your sleep experience visit
helix sleep comm forward slash Tim and
you can get $50 off of your custom
mattress check it out
helix sleep comm forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by peloton and
I'd heard about peloton over and over
again but I ended up getting a peloton
bike in the whole system after I saw my
buddy Kevin Rose I've known forever some
of you know and he showed up at my gate
at my house a while back and he looked
fantastic hey I asked was a dude you
look great what the hell have you been
up doing she's always doing a weird diet
or another but it only lasts like a week
or two so he always regresses to the
mean after like 75 beers and he said
I've been doing peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes in your schedule or
making it to a studio with some type of
commute etc new classes are added every
day and this includes options led by
elite New York City instructors in your
own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
wilfers and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes
and I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and
everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select by music
duration and so on each peloton bike
includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys this nurse of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton let's
bow n e PE l OT o N 1 peloton calm and
enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say men accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip in
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so this hundred dollars off is
a very legit so if you want to get in
your workouts if you want a convenient
and really entertaining way to do
high-intensity interval training or
anything else or you just want to get a
fantastic gift for someone
check out pillowtop one pallet on comm
and enter the code Tim again that's oh
and epe l o t om dot-com and enter the
goat image check out to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you'll want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
you
you